and these football teams all not all
most were built by the support of these
workingclass communities and the men
that were good enough genius from those
communities not to have to go W down the
mind but you know your bill shankley
your jock steens samat buby the iconic
you watch the movie The Three Kings
about the best football managers so
that's Celtic Glasgow Celtic Manchester
United and obviously
Liverpool the the Giants of the game
that they wear who whose shoulders we
all stand upon we're all workingclass
men from within 9 miles of of of a pit
in
Scotland where's where's the equity of
the men who've done all the work over
hundreds of years why why is our equity
and the fact that we've put our bodies
on the
line um sold down the river to to to fit
these quality and diversity quoters I'm
all for it we've got to have skin in the
game we got to have equity in the game